[Music]  when people first came to America they  brought us with we are the ancient ones  and they built churches cathedrals or a  directed stone circle you can make it  better  gradually they abandoned us old  forgotten gods now there are new God's  growing in America and they want to  destroy us was a common shadow I have a  big role field  [Music]  time to ride  did that happen  there's something special going on here  and I feel a part of it  he is dangerous I need you to believe  that there's always a cost of that just  haven't paid it yet  who are beginners I'm going to pick it  up no you take them all this is America  greatest story ever told  are we ready I am  [Music]  [Music]